[Music]
all right so thanks for coming this
morning or this afternoon or wherever
you're at we're gonna talk about a new
more package called recipes and it's
mostly its purpose is mostly about
creating design matrices and data sets
and pre-processing pre-processing them
with various techniques that we'll go
into more so just that maybe get started
talk about a simple like linear model
that we might use and there's a data set
and carat so if you were load carat and
load the data set Sacramento what you'd
find is a data set where there are data
for houses that were sold in Sacramento
within like a five day period so there
are things like the sale price of the
house the square footage number of beds
and baths there's like longitude and
latitude that kind of thing there's also
the type of house which oddly only has
three levels but that's all in that data
set in let's assume that you wanted to
you know build a model to predict the
price of a house so you might think
about using LM to do that and to create
this model use the LM function an LM
takes a formula and so we're be talking
about formulas a little bit and you know
just as a demonstration form that's not
probably how I would model these data
but you might take the log of the price
because it's a very skewed variable
that's your outcomes and sits on the
left-hand side of the tilde there and
then on the right-hand side we have
basically a symbolic representation of
what our model is going to be and
basically this says you know we're going
to model the log of price as a function
of the type of house and its square
footage and that data is in this state
of frame called Sacramento and then with
LM and for the methods you can it can
add a little bit here that's a subset
command so this would filter the
Sacramento data to look only for where
there are three or more bedrooms if
that's the data you learn a lot and so
basically the purpose the current row
chunk if you take it step by step is you
know the first thing we do would be to
subset the data set that
you're gonna model using that command
and then it creates a what's called a
design matrix which is being about
linear regression we usually think of
like you know y is equal to X beta plus
epsilon and the X part of that is the
predictors and that's or what the
old-school people like me would call a
design matrix so the second thing that
that function does is to create a design
matrix now there's two predictors
there's type in square footage but you
end up getting three model terms the
type variable is a factor and that
factor has three levels so when it
creates dummy variables for that it will
actually make two columns of that three
level factor that are 0 and 1 for the
different types of houses and then you
have the third term for square footage
so your your design matrix even though
you have two predictors actually has the
non intercept parts of that design
matrix R there's three columns and then
the third thing it does would be the log
transform the outcome variable which is
priced and then it actually gets around
it actually fitting the linear
regression model using LM dot fit and
some other stuff that we don't normally
mess with but anyway the first two step
set is really the part that it creates a
design matrix and again we're usually
not going to be formulas really in here
but we represent that as X so you know I
wrote for our studio a couple of blog
posts on the foil method and so just
summarizing and you can either link to
those in the slides and you can find
those but basically you know the great
thing about the model form it's very
expressive so you know you can you can
say what your predictor is what your
outcome is you can have these inline
functions like you know logging price
will ensure that you know that happens
and the you know the pre log your data
you can have interaction terms and
nesting and all sorts of great things
with their very expressive and if you're
doing something that's pretty simple
like you know the housing model I was
showing it's extremely efficient and
nice to use under the hood and this is
what the blog post goes into it actually
does some pretty elegant functional
programming which you know surprises me
that that's been or I've been looking at
it for years but that's been around for
quite a long time and you know the
original s language so you don't really
think of ours
a functional programming language but
you know a core part of that the model
matrix in LM and all that is is pretty
nicely done functionally and again I
kind of already mentioned this you can
embed functions in the formula like I
did with price here and the cool thing
about that is you know if we were to log
let's say square footage not only can we
do that in line and it would log that
variable for the data that you have that
you're paying the model on when you go
to use the predict function on a new
data set again you don't have to pre log
square footage you would just give it
you know the comma square footage and
since it knows it's recorded that
transformation the formulator can
actually apply to that to whatever
you're interested in there are some
limitations to what the function sort of
or the formula framework can do and as
I'll talk about in the next few slides
there's some inefficiencies that can
occur there it's mostly I think because
it's a really amazingly well designed
system but it was designed where I think
nobody envisioned having maybe hundreds
of variables in their model and you know
the sort of large-scale modeling that
that people can do today and so I think
it sort of suffers a little bit in those
instances so just some examples of that
is let's say you want to do something a
little more complicated with your
features let's say you have some missing
data that you need to acute and and then
you're putting that data into a model
like this a protector machine or
partially squares or something where you
need the center and scale those values
and so you can envision maybe doing
something with formula where you have an
outcome and Ottilia t and then since you
have these inline functions you might
think that well I'm going to impute my
variable first based on K nearest
neighbors and then you know since I need
a Center in scale I can Center them and
take the output of that and scale it and
that seems fine but that that's
problematic on a lot of levels in terms
of how the formula infrastructure works
and one of those being that if you need
to include a bunch of variables let's
say with K nearest neighbors you would
need to store the original data set and
since the the functional programming bit
of LM deals with each variable
separately you'd end up storing the same
data set many many times for every
variable you would compute so not only
is it problematic just from
a programming standpoint just even if
this code would work it's kind of a bad
idea because you end up having many many
variations or the same data set included
many time so you know this is not a
terribly obscure thing to do but it does
limits you to what you can do in the
Euler method another thing is there are
a lot of modeling functions such as LM
and our parts a good example where you
don't have a non-permanent interface of
the model so you're you're constrained
to always specify your model using a
formula and the problem with that is you
can't really recycle things so if you've
already done the all the work to
generate the design matrix for LM
there's no way to take that recycle it
into our part so that's you know that's
problematic in a way another thing that
I won't get into too much but you can
find it in the blog post that's linked
down here is that the way the form of
method information is stored is pre
inefficient
it's especially inefficient when you
have a large number of variable so we
shown that blog post based on like you
know like using our partner random
forests that if you have a lot of
predictors like in the thousands you can
spend maybe half the time without
modeling function just creating the
design matrix so it does have some
weaknesses for particularly why datasets
it's not really weak in the sense of if
I have millions of data points like rows
but when you think about columns the way
it stores the information about the
formula is is not efficient and it I
don't want say it miss really
exponentially increases in inefficiency
is the number of predictors goes up but
it's not good so that's not great
another thing that isn't necessarily a
limitation but it's always sort of
confounded me is if you're going to do
anything multivariate Li you want to
specify more than one thing on the left
hand side that formula and you would
need to wrap those and see bond which is
just kind of ugly so you know that's
something that you don't like and then
another more fundamental aspect of
formulas is there's really limited set
of roles that variables in your data set
can take and again as we do things that
are more complicated beyond linear
regression that becomes a big sort of
more philosophical limiting factor of
what this formula technology can do
so as an example of that now let's say
you're fitting like a hard work to
remodel whether it's using Stan or or
LME or whatnot you know you have
variables in your data set that are
going to be included in V as outcomes
and predictors but then you have data
that define the hierarchy so if you take
this example from the LME for
documentation you know you have a
subject effect so you're modeling in the
sleep study you're modeling this outcome
quarter reaction as a function of days
and I think this model was a random
coefficient model that would give you a
hard to model based on with rain with
effects probably through the intercept
in days and those intercept those those
random effects are connected to the
subject specification and so a subject
is not a predictor but it's something
you need to carry along with the role is
your your you know your ID variable for
the for the for the methodology and so
you know that's the reason that this
formula looks different than the others
is because that particular package in a
way had to sort of rewrite the formula
method to make that work because that's
what they needed another example is
something called the Bradley Terry 2
package and that's kind of a interesting
package that can model competitions
between between variables so you know
like if you had a boxing data on boxing
you might be modeling whether one person
can win over another and you might have
a toss with people and so the thing is
you might want to model that as a
function lets you reach and so in the
Bradley Terrier model it's basically
like a souped-up logistic regression and
but in order to have that formula method
work in this instance they sort of had
to invent a new way of doing formulas
simply because the current methodology
doesn't let you really specify things
and then another example is there's a
boosting method called mob and you can
Majan it's sort of like a recursive
partitioning model like our part but it
fits linear models and in the terminal
nodes and so when you fit this model you
want to specify which variables are used
for splitting to make the tree and then
which variables are used in the model in
the terminal nodes and so they wrote
wrote a whole new package called
model tools that allow you to have you
know sort of multiple formulas and so
again with the bar here this is a
another situation where people needed
different rows of these predictors you
have predictors that you want to use for
splitting and predictors that you want
to use for modeling and that sort of is
not really gonna happen in the current
standard format method so you know if
you think about maybe other roles once I
could think of is you have the
traditional cricketers and outcomes
sometimes you have stratification
variables like if you're doing a
clinical trial you have you want to
stratify over sites that's a separate
variable again it's not you're not
necessarily doing direct computations on
the but you need it you know a lot of
models when we want to capture the
performance of the model sometimes that
involves other data so if we're
predicting whether something's going to
repay alone or not we don't necessarily
care about the accuracy of that model we
care about the expected loss that comes
through that and if you're going to
compute the expected your profit you're
going to need something like the loan
amount so again it's another variable
that you need to carry along but it's
not really a predictor or an outcome so
you can't really do much with standard
format for that there's a variety of
other things like you know fastening or
random effects like I mentioned now case
weights and offsets or kind of special
cases and in some tons error terms
because there had been some exceptions
written to the form of the method where
you could have like an offset variable
and declare that in the formula method
those are kind of hard-coded things that
are in the base package and they're not
easily extensible to have one for
stratification well there is a strata
function in the survival package but
because my point is if you had an
arbitrary role that you're creating
typically do that with the occurrence
there's formulas so to me
philosophically this is the the larger
problem you know all the all the
programming aspects of formulas we don't
you know like so much like the
inefficiency sometimes can be programmed
out but this is something I think is
really baked into the system so we came
up with a side
something called a recipe and there's a
big food analogy that's gonna happen
here
and so basically idea of a recipe is you
can think of a recipe really it's a
sequence of steps right so you can make
a lasagna
tell you what the ingredients are and it
says you know assemble it like this and
then bake the thing but if you think
about the the linear model we had
earlier you know sequence of steps might
be saying hey you know prices are
outcome that's maybe step one and
declare that and then we might declare
the predictors to be type in square foot
and then another thing we did there LM
was to say well we should log transform
price and then the fourth thing we did
we could say that that sequence of steps
is you know let's convert that type
variable into dummy variables and that
kind of defines the the procedure that
the LM formula method or the formula
method with LM actually did when we
first showed that code and so the thing
is the recipe at least as I've seen it
here is a it's really what we're
intending to do it's not actually doing
it necessarily so one of the issues with
you know model not matrix and all that
is the specification of what you want to
do is couple directly with doing it so
that's one of the reasons you can't
really recycle things very easily
between methodologies so you know what
recipes does is basically says well
let's specify what we want to do and
they we won't actually will delay the
execution of that doing until we you
know say well these are the data we want
to do it lists so we kind of separate
the the planning of what we want to do
from actually making it happen
I'll show you there's a link in the
slides but if you want to install it
it's not a crane yet but there's a
github page for it here and it's got you
know a lot of examples and as you can
imagine if you see my other packages
there's a boatload of documentation
right now if you want to use it you
basically load the or install or load
the dev tools package and then use
install and of our github with my github
idea in recipes and that's currently the
way you get it but it really should be
on cran pretty soon so this will be
linked in the the slides
what you load that just for convenience
I also load a deep liars who can get the
pipe operator and some other things and
so if you wanted to reproduce maybe what
Ellen was doing before we start off I'll
show you a different way to create the
initial recipe but if we only have
prettier turn outcomes if you don't have
any special roles that we want to apply
to our data we can start with basically
a symbolic representation of what should
be in the model by saying price is you
know a function of type in square
footage now the data that you use here
doesn't have to be the original data
it's just what we do in this particular
step is we want to record what data are
in that data frame and what they're
they're attributes are like are they
factors or the numbers and so on so this
doesn't have to be a large data set if
you have a very large data set but once
you have the recipe basically you don't
have to use pipes but I'll do that for
convenience here is you can start adding
steps to the recipe so if we want to
take the original recipe and add a step
that says hey log transform this
variable we could do this little bit and
that basically modifies the recipe to
include a step of that recipe saying no
log that variable called price and then
another thing we can do is to say to add
on to that is to convert type to dummy
variables and so at that point what
we've done is we've come up with a
specification of what the roles are
using this for the method like we used
before and then we've talked about or
described what kind of pre-processing or
actions we want to happen for those
variables by just adding these steps to
them and so it's it's fairly reminiscent
if you've ever used care to the sort of
in some ways like the pre process part
of carrot where you can decide what kind
of pre-processing you want with your
variables but again all this does at
this point is it says well what is a
specification what I want to do and all
we've said at this point was price of
the outcome type in square footed
footage are predictors we're gonna log
price and create dummy variables for
type it doesn't actually do anything but
record those actions and then in this
whole food analogy we want to take this
recipe and prepare it then what prepare
does is basically you can think of it as
training or learning or fitting
the pre-processing steps so for example
we have dummy variables here for tight
so when we do this we're just saying we
want to make too many variables when we
run prepare what it actually does is it
interrogate the data that we've given it
and says okay what are the levels of
type and how exactly am I going to make
those dummy variables so once you start
prepare that's when you're actually
doing computations and storing
information about the specifics of those
actions now one little thing that I've
done here you wouldn't necessarily have
to do is I'm saying retain equal true
and what that says is take the data set
that I've given it and when you estimate
these actions that you're going to do
for the recipe keep the modified version
of that training set around keep it in
this object and that'll stop us from
having to redo computations over and
over again so that's a nice little
feature and you'll see that I'll mention
that in a few minutes when I'm showing
how things are cached when we do this so
again we've specified what the actions
are we've sort of estimated the things
that we need to estimate and then when
you do that it tells you which steps
there's a robust option but right now it
tells you what steps are being executed
as they're executed and then when we
actually want to get the design matrix
to put in LM know the analogy here is
we're going to bake that recipe so we
take the object that we created that has
all the information we needed from the
data and then the new data option here
says well you know apply this this
recipe to this data set so if you're
like in the machine learning of the
project modeling world you might have a
training a test set and so you can apply
these operations that you estimate from
your training set to the test set or to
any new samples that you get it's kind
of like a predictor an apply method
where you're basically projecting all
the pre-processing methods on whatever
data said you're interested in and that
will give you your design matrices so so
that's the basic idea behind recipes as
you specify what you want you estimate
the things that you need to estimate and
then you apply it at will to whatever
data sets that you want which could be
the original data set like it was for
you and that's the basic idea so the
rest of it is sort of talking about the
features and some of the things that you
can do now other things you may have
noticed here is
when I created this step for price you
know I'm not quoting any variables here
and if you're a person who's used
applier you can see some similarity here
where there's a bunch of deep liar like
things happening here like we can pipe
in information and sort of update
objects and you can see I'm not having
to quote variables when I do this but
the interesting thing about recipes is
unlike deep liar we might want to
specify what variables are reason
different steps based on more than their
name so right now and as I'll show you
in a minute
you can specify any number of variables
in these steps by using their name or
the standard apply are things like you
know matches or starts with so you can
use these sort of letting functions
declare what variables are used in steps
but sometimes we might want to do let's
say dummy variables and do it on all the
all the variables that I have in the
data set that are not numeric that let's
say or factor variables and so we also
have these selectors that you can use
that are things like all numeric so if
we want to have a step we can say well
do that for all the numeric predictors
that are in my data set or do it on all
the predictors or all the outcomes and
you can add and subtract fees like you
would with deep liar so for example if
you want to do PCA you can't really do
that on factor variables so you might
want to specify do it on all the
predictors that are numeric and then you
could do that like sort of like you have
here the sequence of selectors you can
always just type two names and with
comma delimited unequivocal names but if
you want to be a little more concise
about what you're doing you can do that
now one interesting aspect of a recipe
is you might be doing or you might be
saying let's do some operations on
variables that don't necessarily like
exist yet so you know for example if
you're going to discretize predictors or
as you'll see in a little bit do you
like pca feature extraction you might do
pca and say give me the number of pca
variables that capture 95 percent of the
variability and that might be four of
them or it might be 100 of them
depending on the data set and the
correlation structure and all that so
what's interesting about recipes is you
might be making you might be wanting to
do operations and the variables that
actually don't not even exist yet but
you don't have to know how many of them
there are
so you know you can do things like you
know matches you know PC one through
nine which would capture you know the
first whatever principle components you
have there and then make sure that you
also capture the numeric predictors but
maybe your outcome is numeric so you
might want to get rid of that one so you
have a really really rich set of way to
specify variables in these recipes and
then we have a whole part of the
vignette or the website has a whole
video on selecting variables and
examples of different ways of doing them
so there's quite a lot there all right
so one cool thing about the recipes is
you can start with a recipe like the one
we have their current recipe we have all
the only thing it does is really logs
the outcome and creates dummy variables
but again let's say you want to Center
and scale your data and then maybe apply
it wouldn't really make sense for this
particular example but let's say you
want to apply PCA signal extraction well
once you have your your recipe eat
whether it's been trained or not you can
just keep adding steps to it and make
that a different a different recipe so
you can sort of save in a way you can
sort of like cache where you've gotten
so far save it as another name and add
other steps to it and I'll show you an
example this towards the end with some
dimension reduction routines so if we
start up this recipe that you know we've
already done some computations on we add
some more stats when we go to prepare
this recipe it doesn't need to redo the
ones that have already been executed so
you can you know when we go to prepare
the recipe with our training set you
know step Center is going to need it to
calculate all the means of the numeric
predictors and step scale or calculate
the standard deviations of all the
numeric predictors and then when it
calculates loadings and things like that
for PCA that's the things that prepare
we'll do it won't redo necessarily the
things the things that you've already
done in the recipe so when I go to run
prepare on this new recipe now I didn't
say new data equal or I'm sorry training
data equal to Sacramento and the reason
I didn't have to do that is this routine
equal true if I don't if I don't retain
me the original predictors the original
data set then I would need to add that
here
but the the value of having that sort of
retaining is when you've got to do this
new centre processing you can see when
it gives you the log of what it's doing
it puts pre-trained here because it's
telling you I don't need to redo those
computations because nothing's changed
and then it does all the estimation
needs to do for the remaining steps so
the cool thing about this is let's say
you want to try a bunch of different
things you want to create a bunch of
different let's say design matrices to
see what works for your model or your
data and let's say again you have some
expensive imputation step that you need
to do before you start doing these
things so you have missing data well you
can do that imputation step which might
be sort of computationally taxing but
you don't have to we do it every time
you create a different design matrix you
can just sort of recycle those
computations and so that saves you a lot
of time potentially when you're praying
these things or if you're doing
something complicated like you were like
an autoencoder or some some really like
complex and big part of these recipes
you can you can basically cache the
results up to that point or just come a
nice feature so you know this is kind of
like the shock loss slide you know here
are the things that I've gotten into
recipes so far you have a lot of basic
things like loots and routes and logs
and polynomials and all that stuff
again anything I'm sort of missing here
whether it's obscure or not please let
me know there are a bunch of things we
can do within codings now so we can do
of course dummy variables which is you
know sort of a standard thing you know
one thing you could do like in the
Sacramento dataset is there's a
predictor for City so you might want to
include the actual city as a as a you
know a different dummy variable in the
model but the problem is you know even
though we have a thousand or so data
points some of these cities you only
have two or three instances in the data
so what you'd like to be able to do is
to you know dynamically say well you
know give me dummy variables but you
know if the frequency of any group in
that and that factor is very small I'd
say like one percent or five percent or
whatever your tolerance is can you
change the factor levels and dump those
into an other level you can do that for
cats and B treat I think you can do that
those packages but you know you can have
a step
would actually sort of reassemble the
factor levels based on that I'm not a
big fan of bidding but you know we have
discretization stats what other cool
thing I had for an example or a data set
I've been working on is let's say you
have a predictor that is a date field
you know it's a date class and are you
know you're probably not going to
analyze it as a date you want to analyze
whether you know the month has an effect
or the day of the week has an effect and
so we have a step that basically can do
all the encoding for dates if you want
to take that single column of your data
and make a bunch of features out of that
for different ways to represent dates or
you can do that
it'll also give you indicators if you
wanted for holidays so you know if
you're modeling something that is
dependent on whether that data is a
holiday or not you might want to have
prettier from your model for that so we
have a nice holiday holiday step similar
to care we have a bunch of filters for
you know highly correlated predictors
and things like that
imputation right now T nearest neighbors
back trees simple mean mode imputation
you know there's a lot more but in there
simple normalization transformation type
things again these are very similar
what's in carrot and again there's
anything missing here seasonal you know
there's a great package code dim red di
M re D and I kind of capitalize on that
where it has a nice interface to a bunch
of dimension rug reduction operations
and so you know right now it's really
easy for you to do a step that's PCA or
kernel pca so you might have a bunch of
variables and this is example I'll show
in a minute you might have a ton of
variables that you just want to do some
plotting lists and you might need to log
some things and maybe do some
transformations and so what I'll show
you in a minute is you can try a bunch
of different dimension reduction
techniques without redoing a bunch of
computations prior that so there's
there's a lot of steps here that will
allow you to do these things and then
there's things like you know basic
expansions and interactions which of
course we need and there's a lot more to
put in you know I've got a little list
and get up you know trying to find a
good auto-encoder package there's more
invitation methods that we can be done
here like pete around singular value
decomposition so there's a lot there
there's a lot of documentation qualities
but again you know Len
now there's something really lacking
here so you know I've already mentioned
you might have said will max you know
the recipe you had before start off with
a formula I thought we were trying to
get away from 40 other method and that'd
be right the the value of using the
formula in the initial recipe is if you
only have an outcome in four outcomes
and predictors you know that's the most
intact lead concise way of doing it
because the situation is not that
complicated in terms of roles but let's
say you do have something more
complicated another way of assembling
the recipe is not using the formula so
you can say you know I want to have a
recipe and the data the original data
set is you know here and then what you
can do is you can take all the variables
that are in that data set and they'll be
available and then you can start to find
their roles so you can add a role for
price being the outcome and these are
not hard code there's not like a
pre-specified list that you have to
choose from so if you want to come up
with some new type of role for whatever
modeling that's what you're doing this
is basically like free text you can put
in whatever you want now we do use
outcome and predictor a lot in the
package so if that's the traditional
role as these things are playing stick
to outcome and stick to predictor but
let's say you want to have the zip code
as a stratification variable so you
might want to fit this linear model
separately for every zip code and so you
could have that column in your data said
come along for the ride not be created
into dummy variables and then when you
extract that using the bake function
you know what its role is and you know
you can get so so it's an example if you
wanted to have a little wrapper around
the knee regression you know the
underlying function that does the linear
model fit this called LM not fit and
takes an X variable which is your design
matrix and it takes a wide area both at
is your vector I think it has to be a
vector of numbers you could you know
have it that function B parameterised in
terms I have a recipe and some data and
then inside that function you could
actually do the prepare bit because the
recipe already has the steps all preset
specified so you don't need to specify
them here and then when you fit L M you
can just get the design matrix by doing
beige
and then add deep layered selectors for
what variables you want to be returned
from that call so if I just want the
predictors my design matrix would
basically be this and then finally what
the outcome I can do the same thing you
know use this bake command but only get
the outcome back and so you know again
if you had stratification variable is
you could say you know roll is you know
strata or whatever you want to select
these things are rolls one other nice
thing about this is since the steps are
all sort of independent of each other
you know this isn't baked in quite yeah
sorry it should use another food analogy
but this isn't really written yet but
the cool thing is is if we have some
pre-processing method that's available
let's say in scikit-learn and we have
scikit-learn installed on a computer you
know wouldn't be hard to write a step
that would then connect our to Python
pass the data to Python have it do the
pre-processing there return all the
information needs to view that technique
on new data and have that come along so
you know are sort of our default compute
engine here but we can certainly since
these things are sort of like
modularized we can certainly do that
with you know Weka or tensorflow or
what-have-you as long as that stuff is
installed when you're in a place where
you're using R and you you know have
code to make that connection we can
start running steps for other packages
basically so that's kind of a little
thing not available yet but it's there
it will be there eventually so here's an
example in our book we took some data
some image segmentation data where
people took a bunch of images of cells
and sometimes the the imaging software
did a good job of saying where the cell
boundary is and other times it didn't so
that's called segmentation of the cell
and so we have a data set where we have
a couple thousand rows we have a couple
thousand images and cells and they have
been already classified as being you
know well segmented or poorly segmented
and they wanted to have a model that
basically predicted that based on a
bunch of imaging derived qualities of
those cells like how
big they are how they're shaped and so
on and so basically we want to build a
model that takes the imaging data and
then makes a prediction on whether that
cell was well segments or poorly second
matter because if we really think
strongly poorly segmented we probably
want to filter those cells out of our
subsequent analysis so you know we can
build a model to uh to do that I'm not
really into model building here what I
want to do is show there's a 58 imaging
predictors in this data set and many of
them are highly highly correlated so if
we want to look at our data and say okay
are there any outliers here are there
any weird features in the data we might
do some dimensional reduction techniques
to figure out how can we project those
58 dimensions down to only a few
dimensions and still capture what's
going on that dataset so I'll use some
steps based on dimensional reduction to
highlight that so let's say you were add
or if you hadn't loaded deep liner
carrot would load those the data is in
this segmentation data object and then
segmentation data has the original
authors pre specified what data they
used for training or Teta the use for
testing so I'm going to use a little
piping here and filter out to make this
training version of the data set a
filter out the I'll keep only the ones
that had case equal train and then I'll
get rid of to two columns in that data
set that are the the data set identifier
and the actual number in the cell like
it's individual cell ID and then I do
the same thing so I have a data set that
only has what their original idea of a
test that was there's about a thousand
cells in each one of these data sets so
what I'll do is I'll estimate any
statistics I need from the training set
like you know the PCA loadings and
things like that and then apply them to
the test set and then that's what I'll
do the graphics on so that's the data
set we'll use so we'll start off with
just a simple recipe the class variable
is the one that is a factor that is
whether something is well segmented or
poorly segmented and I'll say you know
everything else in the data set besides
that class variable is a potential
predictor so that's the basic recipe
where I have declared the
for everything and then what I'm going
to do is sum these predictors are
extremely skewed and so that can mess up
some of the you know things like PCA
that use variance is a an objective
function and how they do their
computations now some of these
predictors are negative in highly skewed
and so there's this thing called the Oh
Johnson transform which is sort of like
the box-cox transformation and it can
have the effect of unscrewing your data
and we use this one instead of box-cox
because box-cox requires your data to be
non-negative it can't be well it can be
zero has to be strictly positive and
some of our data is not like that so
we're saying is all the predictors in
our data set we're going to estimate and
apply this yeah Johnson transformation
to make them a little less cute and then
some of these dimension reduction
techniques we're going to want to Center
and scale our predictors
so again we've only said what we want to
do here we haven't done anything yet
there's three basic steps so far the
weeps were declared and then when I
prepare that recipe I just kept the same
name we're gonna estimate these things
from the training set I'm gonna tell it
not to print out the steps just because
and then I'm going to use this sort an
equal true again and that'll allow us to
recycle all these computations that get
created in subsequent steps so let's say
I want to be principal component
analysis well what I can do is I can
take this sort of pre trained recipe and
an add a step for principal component
analysis and so what this says is hey do
PCA on all the predictors in the data
set now they're all numeric so I don't
need to specify their type and this
other option says is you know give me
the number of PCA components that will
capture 90% basically the variability of
the predictors since though you know I
don't know right now how many predictors
that is but it will give me enough to
capture that information to make sure I
have a pretty good representation my
original data so again what I've done
here is I've just added a I've added a
specification as to what I want but I
haven't actually done piece yet so
there's a summary function for recipes
and when you run a summary function on
it what it tells you is what the
available variables are what they're you
know at this point in the recipe
what their type is or the numbers or the
factors and things like that they
treasure their role and whether there
are variables that have been derived or
the original variables and so you can
see right now I have 59 variables so
there's 40 50 predictors and an outcome
class and and that's what it is because
I haven't done PCA yet I haven't
transformed the same into proponents
because I haven't prepared it and so
then let's say we do that preparation we
don't have to re estimate against
entering and scaling these things but
this fourth step when you do the prepare
function on it computes all the loadings
that we need to do PCA and then if I do
the summary method on that now it's
telling me the things that are available
in the recipe or these variables called
PCA one pco2
is I've actually done the recipe so you
know what variables are available to you
at any given time chain can change
depending on what you're asking it to do
at each step
so prior to PCA even though I said are
in scale and transform these variables
they were there in the original name but
now that I've done PCA they're there
under a different name
so now we have the components we can we
can bake them and get their actual
values for the test set and then if you
just do a simple ggplot you you can see
you know least using PCA what kind of
separation do I have in the data I don't
really see any outliers here per se and
there's you know a fair amount of
overlap in the data so you know you know
how difficult of a modeling problem this
is doesn't mean it's impossible but at
least from a linear classifier
standpoint you can get an idea that
there's some separation but not complete
separation but you might think well you
know there might be some other sort of
feature engineering type things I can do
and one of the things is if you've ever
heard of support vector machines what
you can do is you can let's say project
your original predictors into another
higher dimensional space that that might
be a nonlinear transformation so you can
sort of apply these sort of nominee and
transformations of your data in this
thing called kernel principal component
alysus will do that transformation and
then do PC on top of that expanded
dimensionality of your predictors and
the kernel lab package has a way to do
that we have a step for doing that so
you know our PCA recipe
you
that basic recipe that just did the
centering and scaling and transformation
and so instead of doing the regular PCA
now we can start with that original
recipe and get another one that does put
our kernel principal component analysis
we had to tell what kernel to use and
some of the parameters which I've done
here but when we prepare that we're only
you know this has nothing to do with the
PCA analysis we did previously but it
reactivates everything it needs to for
the kernel pca we bake that to get the
values for the test set and again we can
just ggplot that away here you see a
little is different distributions but I
think there's a little bit more
separation between the classes by doing
this printable this kernel
transformation beforehand so you know
this might be a good sort of feature
engineering step to do you know you can
do like an ISO Map transformation and
things like that there are many other
dimension reduction techniques you can
do a really simple one you can also try
is since we know the classes we can
compute sort of the multi-dimensional
class centroids for each class so we can
take a 58 dimensional space we can find
the center of the distribution for the
well segmented predictors in the center
of the distribution for the poorly set
segmented cells and then this step class
this will we'll compute that and then
when you want to get new predictors it
will actually compute the distance of
every individual data point to the
centroid of the original classes so it's
almost like doing like a linear
discriminant alysus and in here but it's
sort of a as a pre-processing step
rather than as a model and so you can
add a step for that again use all the
predictors since you need to know the
classes to do the centroids you need to
tell what class to use and that's this
variable here and these are distances
which going to be skewed so let's just
log transform those predictors that we
get that come out of this class dist
step and so again we prepare that we
don't the redo computations and then we
bake them the data that comes out of
that is we have the original class you
can see how the matches here it says
give me all the variables in the
computed recipe that start with class
whether it's uppercase C or lowercase C
I mean I have the original class
variable and then the distance
is to the to the poorly segmented class
centroid in the well segment class
centroid and it turns out when you do
that I think you get the most separation
between these these data you do see some
outliers that are induced here so you
might want to look into those data
points but if you you know what we did
here is we did some different feature
engineering steps utilizing this basic
recipe and just kind of layer them on
without having to redo a bunch of
computations so you know you can do the
same thing with models where you might
then put these design matrices into
various models to see what does better
or worse for the for the model that
you're trying to use and hopefully this
is illustrated you know where you can
recycle all these computations and the
sort of simplicity of doing that so
that's the example just to get give me
an idea the next steps where we have
another package that Lionel is working
on called tiny select and recipes for
depends on that for some of the
selectors so as soon as that's on cran
which would be soon we'll get recipes on
crayon another thing that comes in handy
is you know in a recipes right now since
it's not linked directly to any modeling
methods it's kind of like having lunch
in a way where you know you can get
pretty far with it you can get your
design matrices and things like that but
it would be nice to have that integrated
into a bunch of models and at least the
first step of doing that is having a
couple methods and Karen to do that so
you know I'm Karen if you want to
specify your model with some
pre-processing you would do some some
syntax like this where you either use
the formula method or give it the X&Y
datasets and then say which
pre-processing you want to use like you
know PCA or centering and scaling well
well I'm doing right now is creating a
new interface in addition to the ones
that are already there you can say they
have this recipe here's the data you're
going to use for training you don't need
to clear what the pre-processing is
because it's built into that recipe so
you can start specifying your models and
train at least you know which is wrap to
like 200 different types of models and
you know use that to both say what the
predictors and outcomes are but also do
the big sort of expanded set of pre
testing techniques that are here
compared to what is in karat so far so
that's that's one of the next steps and
then after that is you know there's
there's more new modeling packages
coming so these are all integrate with
those modeling packages so that's what's
next on board and thanks for making it
this far
okay let's see um start on the flag ones
if you write such as is it possible
store to return the results later now if
you mean the the results in terms of the
intermediate steps so like when we did
PCA we had the computed loadings yeah
sure I mean that's basically what it
does is it when you do the prepare it
computes the the loadings and they're
you know I used cached I mean they're
basically saved to that object so you
can extract them you can use them on
future data points and whatnot and now
when you say can we store the results if
you're talking about the design matrix
yeah I mean you can you could use bake
on that and save that as an object so if
I'm understanding you those cases yes
you can save and return them that's
that's one of the main things that it
will do let's see the training set what
happens if the variable is being turned
into a dummy variable is not included it
happens if all of the variables and not
included so I'm not quite sure what you
mean you have to declare that you want
to make dummy variables out of factors
so if you if I for example if I didn't
use that step dummy step under bar dummy
for the housing type then when you make
that recipe it's still gonna it's not
gonna be modified so you know formal
automatic well 99% of the time before
the method will automatically convert
factor variables to dummy variables in
mostly modeling functions there are a
lot of exceptions that like reinforce on
our part and a lot of tree based methods
don't do that and then it really tell
you they don't do that
but right now if you want to get dummy
variables you have to use that step
dummy step to make sure that that
happens
so if that's your question that that
would be the answer but otherwise if you
don't do anything to them they just they
stay in the original form and they just
they come along for the ride as there
any steps and recipes to select the test
train break up and what about cross
validation so no and I've thought about
that quite a bit
the thing is any steps that you do they
have to be operations that you would
apply to any data set and so if you
think about splitting data you're going
to differentially do things to each data
set so I'm trying to think of a better
way to say that so one thing I thought
about including is there's a bunch of
subsampling methodologies like if you
have class amounts it's like down
sampling and I thought oh that would
make a great step I should put that in
here but you don't necessarily want to
always down sample so you might want to
down sample your training set but when
you're go to make predictions on your
test set you don't want it down simple
that so I've kind of left splitting
steps out of there and things that would
filter rows for the most part I've done
that now one thing that we're talking
about doing is and this is just we're
just talking about this right now I
haven't implemented anything is being
able to include deep liar type filters
in steps so you might you know pipe in a
step to do centering and scaling but
then you want to let's say filter on
some variable that's there so you can
imagine doing you know filter by or
filter which is in V prior to a recipe
and there are some some of those deeply
operations that I don't see no reason
why they wouldn't work here so there
might be ways of doing that in the
future but I haven't coded them but just
realize anything you do in a step is
something that you're gonna always do to
whatever data you're applying it to so
there might be some some things that you
don't want to include in this step in
terms of cross-validation funny you
should mention that I mean like 80% done
with another our package that I haven't
made public yet that will have a bunch
of like standardized infrastructure for
resampling where there's
cross-validation or time series
resampling and things like that so you
know it's a it's very much like what
model R does
with maybe some expanded ways of doing
things so in there in in that vignette
which I shouldn't talk about things I
haven't released yet there are examples
of how to include recipes it's this
cross-validation scheme so it's not out
there yet but you know probably not the
way too long to to see that further
vignettes yes if you go to the the
recipes again there'll be a link in the
the webinar notes but if you just go to
github and Google and recipes well
you're probably at Hadley has a like a
home set of recipes like food actual
recipes you'll probably find that first
but undermine get my typos github
account if you go to that recipes
directory or repo there's a github IO
link there that has I think there's
three vignettes there and all the
documentation so yeah there's there's a
lot there right now including if you
want to write your own recipe like how
would you do that so there's like a full
example of another recipe that we just
create from scratch and the things you
need to do there why is it necessary to
specify the same devs
data set in both the recipe and prepare
functions you don't really so I did that
out of convenience here but let's say
you have a data set that's like a couple
terabytes or something you've got it in
memory and are when you first get clear
the recipe you can just take the hunt
first hundred data points let's say from
that that that big data set and use that
to define the recipe because the only
thing that the original recipe does is
is get in a county of what variables
were in the data set that and what their
types are so you don't really need to do
that that was just out of convenience
here then when you do prepare then all
the data that goes in to prepare is the
things that you want to estimate
parameters all so so that data set you
want to be the more full and expanded
you know the real data set you want to
do computations are but when you define
the the recipe initially you don't need
to have the complete data set there just
enough for it to get a sense it's like
like radar does is it you know it does
an initial scan of the data to get a
sense of you know what columns in your
CSV file or numbers or dates or what
have you
it kind of does something like that
where it just takes a look at that date
it says so what do I have on here so it
doesn't need to know their distributions
they're they're full probability
distributions written like that where
can I find other examples of recipes
right now those would mostly be in the
vignettes or just training materials
again since I haven't put it on cran it
hasn't been widely circulated so right
now it's sort of limited but you know
I'm hoping that that will be there will
be more for you to bite into there I'm
certainly you know for papers and and
other things that I'm doing now I'm sort
of transitioning over to recipes and all
of the steps that are in there are just
things that I've been doing for gain
analysis for papers or books or whatever
so there will be many more examples but
right now not so much one just extend
carrot rather than create a new recipe
package that's a great question let me
you know I love care and I loved working
on that and I'm still working on that
the thing about carrot is it's very
three monolithic in the sense that if
you've ever used it you know the way
resampling or pre-processing and things
like that it's all embedded into sort of
one big function and so when you want to
make modifications the system that you
know the consequences of doing that
since it's not very modular are pretty
severe to be honest with you and so the
idea of having a separate package is it
sort of isolates there's new things that
you want to do without you worrying
about backward compatibility you don't
have to worry about well wait how does
this affect this and that so it's easier
to make a separate package that has
these steps and these sort of ideas in
it and make adapters for current then
funneling all this stuff in the carrot
another good reason not to do this and
carrot is Karen already has like a lot
of dependencies and so I don't want to
like double down on that just for the
sake of how long it takes granted to
check these things so it's more you know
the idea going forward is to have more
modular blocks of code in different
packages you know like a good example
might be like like do tea pot right I
mean we could always take everything
that people want to do with gg+ and just
add them in the original package but
it's actually easier just to have
extensions of ggplot and different
package same thing with shining right I
mean it's better not to have everything
in one huge package probably the impact
could be helpful to be considered
further categorization of predictor role
as predictors of interest versus
adjustment verbal yeah and so so yeah
you could do that so for example when
you're creating the roles if you create
them sort of sort of like by piping new
roles in that's how you would do that so
go ahead an example where you had a
modeling function where you had
predictors that were used for splitting
and predictors that are used for fitting
models and so you could have a role
called like predictor underbar split or
whatever you want to call it so you you
can do that and then when you use bake
you can just extract those particular
variables or those roles or you could
extract all the variables with you know
these two or three rules so yeah you
definitely have the ability to do that I
was talking to somebody yesterday about
latent variable modeling where you you
have different variables that you would
include with different latent variable
like layers and so that's the same thing
is you could have a role that's for you
know for latent variable Z or another
one for latent variable whatever so you
can do that using roles basically which
is kind of why we created the roles
anyplace to make this work with sparkly
R I don't know I mean that's one
question we've been talking about is
what happens when you have remote data
like we've been paying a lot of
attention to that but there's nothing
coded right now and it's the same thing
with Python or anything else's what do
you do you know it would make sense to
have recipes operate on things that are
not in memory and are that's something
we've been talking and thinking a lot
about there's no code written to do that
sort of like a deep liar though you got
to kind of watch out because there might
be something that spark doesn't do that
let's say recipes does so it would be
weird if you did is in spark and you
want to do centering and scaling well
what spark can probably do that but what
you don't want to do is you don't want
to
try to declare a recipe step that is not
doable let's aim spark or anything else
at least we have to figure out how to
manage that do you want to pull those
data out of the sparking into our to do
that recipe step so there's there's a
layer of complexity there it's doable
but we just have to make sure that we do
that without like bringing the whole
system down sort of thing so there's get
some complexity but that's definitely
things from the from the beginning that
we've been talking about doing so not as
such yet but in the future yes I think
so